bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france les forces afghanes
sont donc en difficulté des
affrontements ont lieu avec les talibans
dans la ville de lashkar gah au sud du
pays le but est donc d'empêcher qu'une
première capitale provinciale ne tombe
aux mains des insurgés quel impact
aurait la chute justement d'une première
capitale provinciale
il est clair que la chute d'une capitale
provinciale
après la chute de plusieurs capitales de
district déjà puisque les talibans
contrôlent déjà une partie importante du
terrain en afghanistan serait
extrêmement mauvais signe ça prouverait
que l'armée afghane n'a pas la capacité
ou peut être la volonté de résister à
l'offensive afghane qui est ainsi
talibane pardon qui est en cours depuis
depuis la fin du printemps depuis que le
que le retrait américain a été a été
confirmé et a réellement commencé
et là évidemment on a vu depuis depuis
des semaines déjà les combats sont
violents et partout les combats ont été
vraiment violent la plupart du temps les
forces afghanes ont reculé voire dans
certains cas on l'a vu avec le
tadjikistan ont passé la frontière quand
elle le pouvait pour se réfugier à
l'extérieur
donc si demain une capitale comme
lashkar gah ouganda ex capitale des
talibans tombait entre leurs mains ce
serait un extrêmement mauvais signe pour
l'avenir
et justement on peut se poser la
question est ce que les forces afghanes
sont capables de contrer les talibans
je veux pas être prophète de de mauvaise
augure
il est clair que les talibans d'une part
bénéficié du soutien d'une partie de la
population en tout cas de une partie de
la population pachtoune qui est
majoritaire en afghanistan et que de
l'autre parent il n'y a pas réellement
je dirais pas qu a pas de volonté de
combattre mais en dehors certaine unité
d'élite on voit que l'armée afghane
l'armée
la flamme à l'armée nationales
d'afghanistan n'a pas vraiment de
d'épiné dorsale et n'a pas ni stratégie
n'est ni les moyens réels de
de faire face aux talibans donc
effectivement on peut se poser la
question et on s'impose d'autant plus
que déjà les talibans contrôle des
postes frontières contrôle des axes
importants qui permettrait le
déploiement des troupes afghanes à
partir de ce moment là on revient que le
terrain le territoire occupé par les
officiels est en train de se réduire
pas encore comme une peau de chagrin
mais c'est quand même vers cela
clairement que l'on va oui justement on
a l'impression que les talibans ont eu
une stratégie bien ficelée en prenant
les postes frontière ouverts les
principales liaisons avec les pays
voisins finalement les talibans ont
d'une part une stratégie d'autre part
une volonté de combattre
ensuite bernard des débuts qui sont très
claires les talibans nous disent qu'ils
l'ont qui leur arrive dit à qui veut
l'entendre qu'ils ont changé qu'ils ne
vont pas réinstaurer théocratie
dictature théocratique comme ça a été le
cas avant l'intervention américaine de
2001 on peut en douter parce qu'on voit
bien que l'idéologie talibane qui sous
tend cette volonté de combattre est en
contact et on voit bien que ce qui se
passe dans les territoires et sont
aujourd'hui soumis à l'autorité et à vis
des talibans
c'est exactement ce qui se passait avant
2001 les pieds ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs depuis chaque fois qu'ils ont
pris le contrôle d'une zone
les petites filles qui vont aller que ne
peuvent que l'école les écoles sont
fermées des femmes sont voilées reste à
la maison
on voit bien que ce qui se réinstallent
c'est un système talibans est
manifestement ce système extrémiste
correspond à ce que vaut une partie de
la population
en tout cas les pachtouns et ça explique
certainement le soutien dont dont les
talibans bénéficient dans une partie de
la population avec ce constat que vous
dressez est ce que on peut dire que
finalement ces vingt ans de guerre pour
rien l'avenir
j'avais écrit nulle part bien entendu
mais on est on est un peu forcé de faire
le parallèle avec ce qui s'est passé
après le retrait soviétique
d'afghanistan
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut comprendre en afghanistan
c'est que la population est globalement
très jeune et que la majorité n'a pas la
majorité la quasi-totalité des afghans
et des parents des afghans aujourd'hui
n'ont jamais connu une autre situation
que la guerre depuis l'occupation
soviétique en passant par en arrivant
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en passant
par l'intervention américaine et c'est
donc on est dans un pays très pauvre où
la culture est déjà objectif banc dans
certaines parties population une culture
violente est extrêmement patriarcale on
voit assez mal les conditions d'un
équilibre social et politique sont loin
d'être réunies et malheureusement je
pense que sans sans insulter l'avenir
on peut dire que les possibles femmes
les perspectives sont assez sombres pour
ce pays malheureusement
et effectivement si sassou de se
réaliser on pourrait dire que ça a été
vain autant de sacrifices et des
centaines de milliers de morts et des
millions de personnes déplacées pour
rien merci beaucoup claude moniquet pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en stratégie sécurité
et contre terrorisme
merci à vous merci